before the year 1999 no sci-fi story had
ever depicted anyone quite like bender
Futurama 30% iron
40% titanium and 40 percent zinc
automaton of course bender did a whole
lot of really terrible stuff over the
course of Futurama as many seasons and
movies but these have got to be some of
the absolute worst relative to some of
benders other crimes stealing from
people in need might not seem too bad
but it's hardly great either the 1999
Futurama episode Xmas story introduces
the show's hilariously bleak take on
Christmases future in the year 3000
Santa Claus is real but he's a
malfunctioning robot convinced that all
humans are on the naughty list so he
spends Christmas Eve hunting down and
killing any people foolish enough to
leave their homes Santa has something
very special in his sack for you to
[Music]
[Applause]
the robots of New York City are exempt
from Santa's attacks and can do what
they want on Christmas which for bender
means heading down to the local robot
soup kitchen where homeless and
down-on-their-luck BOTS can get a free
bowl of booze yeah yeah man listen I'm
one of those lazy homeless bums I've
been hearing about could you point me to
the free booze after taking what's
essentially food out of the mouths of
essentially starving robots Bentley
convinces some other homeless robots to
help him loot and rob from the city's
other inhabitants no wait I know these
guys they got nothing merry Christmas
from bender everyone in a move that's
heavily criticized by the show's women
the 2003 Futurama episode bend her finds
bender posing as a female robot in order
to compete at the 3004 Earth Olympics
and then undergo a surgical procedure to
become a fembot permanently so as to
pull off a number of scams attending the
Olympics as a spectator
Mendon notices that the robot bending
events are about to begin
naturally he decides he could have a go
himself something tells me I could
easily beat those trained professionals
but after seeing what the robots in his
leg are capable of bender becomes
convinced that his late-breaking dream
of Olympic glory has been dashed until
he gets the idea to game the competition
by entering the female robot bending
field
my name is toilet and I'm from Robo dia
bender racks up a line of perfect scores
and wins five gold medals for the Grand
Duchy of robonia but panics when he has
to submit an engine oil check ensuring
that no mail robot winners cheated by
posing as fembots
in order to keep his medals bender asks
Professor Farnsworth to perform a gender
changing surgery on him bender goes
through with it passes the test and Quay
let then uses her newly acquired
feminine wiles to seduce celebrity robot
cow
ilan so it's to scam him out of a number
of expensive gifts and then marry him so
she can then divorce the guy and acquire
half of his fortune
yikes give it girl enjoy yourself
without being judged Futurama is 2002
episode a pharaoh to remember is driven
by how bender always lashes out in
hugely extravagant ways whenever he
doesn't get the attention he thinks he
deserves for his criminal acts in this
case those crimes involved robbing a
municipal pool and stenciling a graffiti
tribute to himself
luckily bender gets his chance to cement
his legacy when after the crew delivers
a giant block to an ancient Egypt like
planet he's taken by the planets rulers
as a slave call it a hunch but I've got
a bad feeling about this
later after the planets cruel vero is
crushed the wall of prophecy determines
banded to be the new leader mostly
thanks to benders crude tampering with
the wall of prophecy this society is a
bunch of idiots
bender quickly takes to his new role and
cruelly forces an army of slaves to
build a 284,000 mile-high statue in His
image
but then bender fears the statue itself
will overshadow him and orders the
slaves to tear it down and build a newer
smaller one which predictably leads to a
rebellion suddenly tired after he's
overthrown bender is thrown into a tomb
and left for dead luckily for him his
last request is granted by his
executioner's and his best friends get
interned with him
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not really much of a stretch to
call bender a narcissist
in fact he nearly always acts in his own
self-interest and isn't exactly a verse
to laughing at the misfortune of others
honey we love you sure baby I know it
and while he may always claim to want to
kill all humans
benda would probably rather just be
worshipped instead but that also means
he really can't handle too much positive
attention being paid to others either
and that's usually when he gets most
violent in the 1999 episode I second
that emotion
the Planet Express gang forces bender to
get an empathy chip installed following
his ghastly treatment of Leela's cute
pet nibbler after Leela leaves on the
gigantic can opener she needs to get
into a barrel of food for nibbler it's
powerful magnet sucks in bender and
tears him half to pieces you'll kill my
father I know you've come back for me
when bender threatens to strangle the
animal niblet makes good on the robots
most iconic taunt break my shiny metal
ass hey bite my shiny metal ass bite my
shiny metal ass Oh
unfortunately niblet chip sees Fang
while doing sir a trip to the vet ganas
niblet some additional sympathy which
enrages bender further as does the
birthday party the little guy gets when
the veterinarian speculates nibbler is
five years old bender retaliates by
making a bender is great cake which also
goes kinda badly
of course that's the last straw
so bender flushes nibbler down the
toilet bender may have never achieved
his desire to kill all humans but in the
2003 episode Spanish fry he almost
causes one to lose something pretty
precious during a Planet Express camping
trip fry goes out hunting for Bigfoot
and is subsequently abducted by aliens
Wow what is your family plates a probe
one the next morning he stumbles back to
the campsite
totally unharmed except for the fact
that his nose is completely gone I think
it's sweet you chopped off your nose if
you look more like your hero be bender a
news report soon reveals the real reason
behind the area's recent uptick in alien
abductions purchas are hunting humans
and chopping off their noses or human
horns to sell on distant worlds as
aphrodisiacs the gang soon tracks down
Fry's nose finding that it was purchased
by recurring villain ler ruler of
Omicron Persei 8 who is looking to
rekindle the spark in his marriage
turned under and under returns Fry's
nose and Leela reattaches it with a
laser and it seems like all's well that
ends well until bender opens his big
mouth that is just a robo curiosity why
would you use it guys knows for an
aphrodisiac instead of is you know
winged dang doodle lure reveals that he
thought the human nose was in fact the
phallus and bender helpfully corrects
him which goes kind of badly for fry him
fry is ultimately spared Beiler when ler
and Donder reconnect emotionally but
that doesn't change the fact that bender
came very very close to getting his best
friend's manhood chopped off then again
no I'm gonna chop off my antennae Hey
yeah that sounds good can I give you a
hand
well doctors are generally well
compensated for the considerable
expertise planet
press staff dr. John Zoidberg isn't so
lucky he's a weird monster who smells
like eats garbage and does I'm right in
the 2000 episode the deep south however
Lloyd Berg catches a lucky break after a
series of events caused the Planet
Express ship and its crew to become
stuck at the bottom of the ocean
Zoidberg goes out exploring and
discovers a large luxurious shell he
decides that this will be his new home
and that he'll make a go of life under
the sea
what's so far-fetched about mermaids I
mean there's all sorts of weird sea
creatures here in the future like dr.
Zoidberg toward the end of the episode
with the ship in working order again the
crew prepares to leave
Zoidberg says goodbye only to discover
that his beautiful shell has burned down
how did this happen that's a very good
question so that's where I left my cigar
that just raises further questions of
all the people who need their house
burning down the least
Zoidberg has to be top so bender
destroying the lobsters new shell
through outright carelessness seems like
a major low point after an unusually
profitable period of business Professor
Farnsworth pays for some upgrades to the
Planet Express ship in 2002 Love &
Rocket including the addition of a
flirty female voice AI if you don't like
the station's you could just play with
my buttons till you find something we
both enjoy
benda quickly falls in love with the
ship
she falls even hotter for him and then
almost immediately
bender grows bored with the relationship
and cheats on the ship with a series of
what he calls cheap floozies on the side
as well as the preserved head of Lucy
Liu who are you talking to no one baby
Lucy Liu is the only girl for bender I
love you naturally the ship gets jealous
and clingy has been a lies about his
affairs and remains aloof
not only does bender treat the AI poorly
but he unceremoniously dumps her and
sends her into an emotional meltdown
right in the middle of an Omicron Ian
fleets attack on delivery vessel and its
crew this
sends the ship into both physical and
emotional freefall benda however is no
worse for wear
in 2011 bender AMA nearly saw bender
fulfill his casual mission statement to
kill all humans but it actually went
down completely by accident really the
end result of an entirely different
deplorable action committed by the robot
in this episode Professor Farnsworth
invents a duplication machine which
creates two perfect although smaller
copies of an object as Farnsworth grows
ever older he grows colder and smaller
so he uses the device to create two
smaller sweaters he can wear
simultaneously the professor asks bender
to fold those new sweaters and the robot
agrees but not without a little whining
first hoping to get out of any more
chores bender uses the duplicator to
make two tiny benders and orders them to
fold the sweaters obviously they refused
and instead choose to join bender in
living his best life when they are later
asked to do another minor task the
little benders do just what they're
bound to do and create clones of
themselves to do it for them eventually
the clones keep duplicating and adding
up getting progressively smaller with
each generation
now robots need alcohol for fuel and the
many benders quickly consume the world's
entire supply of alcohol after this the
microscopic Bender clones get to work
converting water molecules into alcohol
which gets every living thing on earth
absolutely hammered it all turns out
okay in the end but not without a little
trouble first let's face it
bender is no role model nobody should
imitate the things he does he's a
selfish callous calculating madman who
manipulates his friends and the world at
large alike to serve his various
destructive whims but he's also
hilarious and can likely be counted as
the most memorable character on Futurama
a chock full of
memorable characters but is there a
danger in placing someone like bender up
on the pedestal that is television will
people naturally imitate and emulate
anyone they see on TV just because they
find them funny well that's the question
behind the 2003 episode bender should
not be allowed on TV during this episode
bender lands a role in his favorite
robot soap opera all my circuits and
quickly becomes a breakout star by
essentially playing himself a singing
booze guzzling cigar smoking petty thief
we need this edgy sweeps ready robot on
our network bender can you continue to
drink smoke and steal things on TV yes I
can the show surges in popularity
especially as more and more kids start
to watch transfixed by Bendis antics in
the wake of this nearly all the show's
recurring child characters end up trying
to break stuff abuse people mouth often
smoke just like bender much like bender
himself however Dwight qubit and tinny
Tim soon find themselves angling for a
bigger score so they rob bender leading
him to start a crusade to get himself
off television although he'll probably
tell you otherwise bender isn't actually
great at everything what take his
cooking for example bender dreams of
becoming a renowned chef but every time
he tries to make a meal for the Planet
Express crew it goes horribly horribly
wrong the pie is ready you guys like
swarms of things right nevertheless he
persists harboring a borderline
obsession with the forearmed respirator
and celebrity chef elzar in the 2000
episode Vanda gets made bender fry and
Leela get to attend a taping of elzar's
TV cooking show bender is amped but his
enthusiasm quickly becomes obnoxious for
everyone else bender please try to be a
little quieter no you shut up
while making down-home Neptune style
gumbo elsa decides to knock it up a
notch with a blast from respites weasel
bender of course wants him to kick it up
yet another
and elzar reluctantly agrees and then
this happens I gotta get this knock up
knocking on film Lila of course is then
blinded for the rest of the episode oh
wait you serious let me laugh even
harder check out one of their newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]